what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
they've been off the bankers ain't been
at work they took a holiday
we didn't take a holiday well we kind of
took a holiday but that's a different
thing don't forget that lunch money is
now sponsored by block five
block five has three products you can
buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar loan
or you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point percent apy
in an interest bearing account go get a
block by account
go to blockby.com pomp yo for real go
get a blackfy account you can earn up to
8.6
apy what are you doing go get a blackfy
account blockby.com
pomp what's up hey guys i'm so excited
to be back
okay um ready oh shoot i forgot my
earrings
okay um me too so
um for the first time ever
forbes published their forbes crypto
awards and i'm reading this article like
i would read a normal article
and all of a sudden i'm like oh in our
forbes award judge anthony pompliano
credits
powell for and i'm like did you
participate in this i was the judge
i was the guest judge yeah me and
michael del rey we did it we got on
so we talked about it we discussed we uh
uh deliberately deliberated and we
decided
on the uh on the different people who
won awards so
who is the the crypto person of the year
jerome powell what up jerry stockpicker
appreciate you
ran a three trillion dollar marketing
campaign for bitcoin he woke the world
up
he said
he was just going to print a bunch of
money people said i ain't going to hold
on to that money that's going to be
devalued and they took their money and
they
and they started to put into bitcoin and
now what you're seeing is every
institution in the world wants bitcoin
why do they want bitcoin
because it's a better store of value
than holding dollars but the problem is
that the bitcoiners who are holding the
bitcoin
we ain't selling and so the only way to
accommodate
both the sellers or the bitcoin holders
and the billions of dollars of
institutional demand that's coming
is for the price to rapidly appreciate
there's only one thing that can move
the supply ain't moving the price has to
move because demand is increasing so
fast
so let's see what happens so so i
thought the disruptive innovator was
interesting caitlyn long what can you
tell us about her
caitlyn long shout out uh we're an
investor
in caitlin's company yeah uh so i kind
of had to
throw out some suggestions for
disruptive innovator and then i had to
kind of recuse myself a little bit
and let michael make the final decision
here he went with caitlyn
she basically is helping to pioneer a
new banking
uh model in uh in wyoming and so
it's pretty cool to kind of see how
disruptive that'll be to uh
to the banking world cool speaking of
bitcoin and me
reading articles not knowing anthony's
part of them here's another one
miami mayor francis suarez may try to
turn his city into a hotbed for
cryptocurrency innovation
he said that he is absolutely exploring
making miami
home to the country's first
cryptocentric municipal government
seemingly endorsing concepts from
tokenization to on-chain voting
and he tagged anthony pompliano for the
suggestion
i was there when this happened tell them
so what did you suggest
i don't want to reveal too much yet but
i got some news in 2021
i'm a big fan of mayor miami he uh he
gets it
because you know what he's doing he's
not trying to be the smartest guy in the
room
he's simply saying how can i empower
people to
be successful you got a company great
what do you need oh you're a
tech employee what do you need oh you're
into
uh artificial intelligence what do you
need how can i
help and we haven't seen that from
politicians in a long time
this ain't rocket science literally just
simply
asking how can i help you is
groundbreaking in the political
sphere it's also groundbreaking in
interpersonal relationships
saying to somebody how can i help is
very nice i have a friend that i'm not
going to name
because i don't know if he would be
comfortable with me sharing this
publicly but i have a very good friend
of mine
um who one time said i figured out
relationships
sometimes the goal is just to be
supportive
not helpful that was a very
very very because like an intelligent
expert
relationship any woman will tell you
sometimes i just want to complain and
vent
i don't need you solving my problems i
can solve my problems i just want to
vent
but he is the worst person to vent to
because he will never say anything bad
about anybody so i'm
i'm sitting there looking like you know
what why do you need to say why do you
need to say something bad about people
no i just mean like sometimes when you
want to vet and then he doesn't give me
the reaction
i want so i'm like ugh and i look like a
jerk you don't know what they're going
through
you don't know what i'm going through i
know everything you're going through i
want nothing to do with it
all right next zhang zhen a 37 year old
citizen
journalist who was the first known
person to face
it is the first known person to face
trial for chronicling
china's outbreak a chinese court
sentenced her
to four years in prison
sending a stark warning to those
challenging the government's official
narrative of the pandemic god i'm so
happy i don't live in china what do you
think about this
i don't like it and and i again
in china the news media is tightly
controlled by the state
we've seen this before it happened in
bulgaria it's happening in other
countries
when when the government has control of
the news media
you there is no freedom of speech you
can't
accurately document what's going on
because if you do you're going to get
sentenced to four years in prison
so i don't want to say much but what i
will say is
another data point that communism is not
cool
socialism is not cool if you like
communism or you like socialism you
should move to china
if you don't like those things you
should hang out here in the united
states censorship is bad
in any situation okay ready
the virus started in china go ahead they
did
it's just the fact like we just so that
we're clear that that is a
fact but somehow why are you why are you
bringing this
because somehow we're trying to like
rewrite history they're trying to put
people
in jail for chronicling this like okay
that is a fact
but go ahead giving to charity is about
to pay off a little more
if the latest coveted relief bill
becomes law
the relief bill features 600 stimulus
checks 300
unemployment supplement payments and a
second round of forgivable loans for
small businesses
it also sets a host of changes to the
tax code including an extension of
incentives
to encourage taxpayers to donate to
worthy
causes so basically what's the change to
the tax code
so basically the cares act established
an above-the-line deduction allowing a
write-off
of up to 300 in cash donations but
i think you can i think you can write
off
lawmakers call for increasing the right
off to 600 for joint filer starting next
year
and 300. that's good i think that's good
you should give to charity it by the way
uh over the holiday break i
um decided to waste a bunch of time
helping dave portnoy yeah erica nardini
and barstool and i say waste a bunch of
time because
uh i sat on my phone and was tweeting
away and planner was very mad at me
because i wasn't uh participating or
paying attention to other things that i
should have been
but in my mind i wasn't wasting time um
and we raised some money
i think that we're now over 320 000 for
the barstool fund
in crypto donations we're way over a
million dollars total
uh from bitcoin and crypto community uh
i think they crossed over seven million
dollars total for the barstool fund
uh and what they're basically doing is
they're trying to help small businesses
so
if you are uh feeling like you're
getting a good giving mood
you should go to barstoolfun.com and you
should give you can give dollars or
crypto if you give crypto it and it's
appreciated it's actually more tax
efficient and the small business gets
more
um so go check it out barcelona.com
speaking of helping small businesses
guys i'm going to be interviewing marcus
lemonis
very soon go sign up at
theprofile.substack.com
you almost said the url wrong i know i
wanted to say readtheprofile.com but
either one works
read the profile.com okay hey he's
playing with my candle
so you know sarah blakely the the
founder of spanx
she has a brother so cnbc interviewed
their mom because both kids turned out
pretty successful um sarah blakely
obviously founded spanx her brother
ford created messaging platform zingle
which was acquired by medallia for 42
million in 2019.
and so they asked the mom like what's
what's the key to success
and she said it is important it was
important for me to give them freedom to
explore what they wanted to do with
their lives they had a lot of free time
which i don't think
kids do today i think creative free time
is so important
things are so programmed now with sports
and activities that their parents drive
them to constantly we didn't do that
and apparently sarah blakely as a child
would say mom i don't have anything to
do
and she would be bored and her mom would
say you've got a lot of toys figure it
out
i was also very bored as a kid like i
think i actually do think that boredom
can spark
creativity because i for me i didn't
have a lot to do so i started writing
i don't know that's paid off well um i
did not start writing when i was
born they were like right now i ain't
doing it
when you're an only child then you
you're bored you start writing
i want to know what i did when i was
bored what i went and i found my
brothers and i annoyed the hell out of
them i
beat them up or we competed in something
that that i mean that says
a lot about you it says a lot about me
we just competed like literally you want
to eat breakfast okay who could eat the
cereal faster
but but also fun fact about the sarah
blakely household
when they were little um they would
always have dinner at the dinner table
together and their dad would ask would
have them go around the table and
everybody would say one thing that they
failed
at that day and if it wasn't like a
meaty
you know failure he would get
disappointed
because he's like you're not trying hard
enough you're not taking risks you're
not experimenting
so i think that that's also kind of a
she she
because of that experience she started
to see failure as an opportunity to do
something more
and try again we weren't failing we were
trying to win
we still trying to win all right next
ask lunch money time
put your questions below with hashtag
ask lm
okay taraskvostiak
best domino's pizza toppings i can't
believe nobody has asked this yet
uh pepperoni that's all yeah just
pepperoni
we usually get a large pan pizza or
whatever hand tossed pizza whatever the
normal freaking thing is no
nothing special pepperoni but the key
the key if you order at domino's is to
get the cheesy bread it ain't healthy
for you
it might not go down real easy but when
you put it in your mouth
you salivate like it just sits in your
mouth and you're like this
this is what life is it's really greasy
guys this is what life is
kind of greasy all right it does not go
down
tony lights up pimp i miss the jokes oh
i do too maybe i'll bring them back pump
i'm trying to spread more information on
crypto and want to focus on beginners
got any books or
you recommend or podcasts for brand new
people who don't know anything about
bitcoin or cryptocurrency
there's two books that i recommend the
first is the bitcoin standard
classic have to read it actually three
books that i recommend
bitcoin standard the second one is this
one
bitcoin hard money you can't [ __ ] with
it's from jason williams
my buddy and partner go get this book on
amazon
he's been selling them like crazy go get
it go get it it's awesome
and then uh bitcoin billionaires a
little bit more entertainment ben
mesrick
i wrote about the winklevoss twins uh i
liked it
it's awesome i think ben's awesome i
think cameron and tyler doing a
fantastic job
so that's it bitcoin billionaires uh
bitcoin
hard money you can't f with and uh the
bitcoin standard when is somebody gonna
write a book about me
okay next question tom wallace
ask the hard questions you two are great
together but i'm sure off-camera things
aren't always so rosy
are there any hot button topics that you
two vehemently disagree on
yeah tom you're a funny guy that is
bait and i ain't taking
of you you have such a great sense of
humor all right guys
this is a great end of the show that's
it we'll see you tomorrow
tom you get yo man tom
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends